>> Tucker: ANY WAY THE
DEMOCRATS ENTERING CONGRESS, OF
COURSE, ONE OF THE TOP INTEREST,
ONE OF THE TOP PUBLIC
POLICIES, IS ARMING THE
POPULATION, JUST A DECADE AGO,
ABOUT A QUARTER OF CANDIDATES
BACKED BY THE NRA WHERE, IN
FACT, DEMOCRATS.
NOW THE NUMBER OF NRA-BACKED
DEMOCRATS IS 3.
MEANWHILE, HE KNEW PAUL MAX AS
THEIR TOP ISSUE AFTER
SINGLE-PAYER HEALTH CARE IS
REPEALING THE SECOND AMENDMENT
IN ORDER TO BAN GUNS.
A LAWYER, FORMER ADVISOR TO
HILLARY CLINTON, JOINS US
TONIGHT.
RICHARD, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
IS THIS REALLY THE TIME, AS THE
COUNTRY IS BECOMING MORE
CHAOTIC, TO DISARM THE
POPULATION?
>> I CAN'T SPEAK FOR THESE
PEOPLE RESPONDING TO THE POLL, I
CAN TELL YOU WHAT NANCY PELOSI"
DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING ABOUT,
WHICH IS BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WHICH 90% PLUS OF LISA PUBLIC
SUPPORTS, WHICH HAD 54 VOTES IN
THE SENATE WHEN IT WAS PUTTING A
BILL TO REQUIRE --
>> Tucker: WE'VE SAID THIS A
MILLION TIMES, DEMOCRATS PULLED
IN A LEGITIMATE POLL, THEIR
NUMBER TWO ISSUE IS
REPEALING THE SECOND AMENDMENT,
PRACTICALLY DISARMING THE
POPULATION, THERE ARE GOING TO
BE CALLS FOR THAT.
VOTERS WANT THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES TO CALL FOR IT.
IS THIS THE TIME, AND SHOULD IT
MAKE THE REST OF US NERVOUS,
AMERICA GETTING CRAZIER,
OBVIOUSLY, TO DISARM ALL PEOPLE?
>> I DON'T BUY THE NOTION THAT
THAT WAS A LEGIT POLL, A QUARTER
OF DEMOCRATS THINK REPEALING THE
SECOND AMENDMENT -- WHAT I
THINK, DEMOCRATS ARE STAYING,
WHAT JUSTICE SCALIA SAID IN THE
FAMOUS HELLER DECISION.
THE ONE CASE THAT MUCH OF THE
SUPREME COURT, WHERE HE SAID, A
PERSON HAS A RIGHT TO A HANDGUN
TO PROTECT THEIR HOME, PERIOD,
AND LEGITIMATE REGULATION IN
TERMS OF GUNS AND PLACES THAT
THEY CAN'T BE TAKEN, SCHOOLS
COME PLACES, CONDITIONS ON THEIR
SALE --
>> Tucker: WE HAVE ALL OF
THOSE LAWS ALREADY.
>> TALK ABOUT REPEALING THAT --
>> Tucker: NOT STOP LYING,
JUST FOR A SECOND.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO STOP MASS
SHOOTINGS, REALLY, UNLESS YOU
TAKE ALL OF THE GUNS AWAY, THAT
IS THE TRUTH, AND EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT, HONESTLY.
SO THAT IS KIND OF THE GOAL, AND
EVERYONE REALLY KNOWS THAT, AND
I'M JUST WONDERING, WHAT IS THE
ARGUMENT HERE?
IF YOU ARE ARGUING
SIMULTANEOUSLY THAT THE POLICE
ARE RACIST AND CAN'T BE TRUSTED,
WHICH BETO AND OTHER CANDIDATES
HAVE ARGUED, AND POPULATION
CAN'T BE TRUSTED TO DEFEND
ITSELF AND CAN'T HAVE FIREARMS,
WHAT ARE YOU REALLY SAYING?
>> I THINK WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING -- AND FRANKLY, IT
REPUBLICANS WISH THEY HAD BEEN
SAYING IT, BECAUSE THE ONES
BACKED BY THE NRA, THEY LOST TO
DEMOCRATS SAYING "WE WANT BACK
ON CHECK LAWS" AND SO FORTH.
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING, IS THINGS
HAVE GOTTEN OUT OF WHACK.
THE UNITED STATES IS UNIQUE IN
THE WORLD, IT IS NOT A MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEM, THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS ANYWHERE ELSE IN
THE WORLD, BUT WE HAVE THIS
HORRIBLE GUN PROBLEM HERE.
>> Tucker: WE DON'T, BECAUSE
MOST AMERICANS ARE NOT A THREAT
TO ANYBODY.
THIS IS WHAT MAKES ME NERVOUS, A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE
COMMIT THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
OF SHOOTINGS.
BUT WE ARE NOT THINKING CLEARLY
ABOUT HOW TO DISARM THEM.
ALL OF THESE LAWS APPLY TO ME.
I KNOW POSE NO THREAT TO ANYONE.
SO WHY NOT LEAVE ME AND NORMAL
PEOPLE OUT OF IT, WHO POSE NO
CONCEIVABLE THREAT, AND FOCUS ON
THE POTENTIAL THREATS.
NO ONE EVER IS UP FOR DOING
THAT.
WE ALL HAVE TO BE DISARMED.
WHY?
>> NO ONE IS TALKING ABOUT
DISARMING ANYBODY.
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE SAYING, WE
SHOULD HAVE BACKGROUND CHECKS SO
LUNATICS DON'T HAVE THE ACCESS
TO GUNS.
>> Tucker: THE MOST RECENT
SHOOTING -- MANY OF THESE
SHOOTINGS -- HAVE BEEN PAID BY
PEOPLE WHO HAD BACK ON CHECK
SPARED THE LATEST SHOOTER,
OBVIOUSLY, YOU JUST ON
CALIFORNIA COME WITH THREE BACK
ON TRACK.
THE TRUTH IS, IT IS NOT JUST
BACK ON CHECKS COME WITH NOBODY
REALLY OPPOSES.
IT IS LIMITING THE KIND OF
FIREARMS YOU CAN BUY, LIMITING
THE SIZE OF THE MAGAZINES YOU
CAN USE, LIMITING THE KIND OF
AMMUNITION YOU CAN USE AND
PURCHASE.
THESE ARE LAWS, RESTRICTIONS,
THAT AFFECT NORMAL PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
WHY IS THAT?
>> WHEN YOU SAY NOBODY REALLY
OPPOSES -- WHEN YOU HAVE
REPUBLICAN LEADERS TO AFFIRM THE
FACT --
>> Tucker: LETS BE SERIOUS.
BACKGROUND CHECKS, I BUY ON, SO
I KNOW, THEY ARE IN PLACE.
YOU GO THROUGH IT WHEN YOU BUY A
GUN.
WHY WOULD A MAGAZINE
RESTRICTION, AND AMMO
RESTRICTION, OR AN ASSAULT RIFLE
RESTRICTION, APPLY TO ME?
WHY AM I NOT TRUSTED TO BUY ANY
KIND OF GONE I WANT?
I'M CONFUSED, HONESTLY?
>> THE ANALOGY I WOULD USE,
BASICALLY MAKING CARS AT SAVER.
THEY USED TO BE A LOT MORE
ITALIANS ON THE ROAD, AND WITH
THINGS LIKE SEAT BELTS, AIRBAGS,
AND OTHER THINGS.
VEHICLES THAT COULD BASICALLY
CRUSH WITHOUT CRUSHING THE
PASSENGER.
AND BACKGROUND CHECKS IS THE
FIRST WAY TO GO.
>> Tucker: NY -- SINCERE
QUESTION -- THE ASSAULT RIFLE
BAN, A GUN THAT LOOKS SCARY
SHOULD BE BANNED, OKAY, THAT IS
THE POSITION, AND A LOT OF
CANDIDATES SAY THEY SHOULD BE
CONFISCATED.
WHY SHOULD MY RIGHT TO BUY THAT
GUN BE INFRINGED?
NO, IT IS THOUGH.
WHY SHOULDN'T I BE ABLE TO BUY
THAT GUN?
I'M AN AMERICAN CITIZEN, I DON'T
POSE A THREAT TO ANYBODY.
WHY CAN'T I HAVE NOT GONE?
>> I THINK THE CONCERN IS PEOPLE
GET THEIR HANDS ON ASSAULT
WEAPONS WHO COMMIT THESE
CRIMES -- IF YOU WANT TO USE
YOUR ASSAULT WEAPON ON A RANGE,
GO TO A RANGE, KEEP THE GUN THEY
ARE, AND HE WAS THAT THEY ARE.
>> Tucker: MAYBE I WANTED IN
MY HOUSE.
>> YOU WANT AN ASSAULT WEAPON TO
DEFEND YOUR HOUSE?
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
IS WE DON'T TRUST OF THE
POPULATION OF THE COUNTRY.
WE DON'T THINK YOU ARE
AUTONOMOUS, WE DON'T THINK YOU
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS FOR YOURSELF.
WE JUST DON'T TRUST YOU.
AND I'M SAYING, WHY WOULD I EVER
VOTE FOR SOMEONE WHO DIDN'T
TRUST ME TO HAVE AN AR-15 AT
HOME, HONESTLY?
>> WE DIDN'T TRUST PEOPLE TO
DRIVE WITHOUT SEAT BELTS OR
AIRBAGS ARE SO FORTH, WE
INSTITUTED THINGS ARE GOING TO
MAKE PEOPLE SAFER.
WHAT WE ARE SAYING --
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T USE A CAR
TO DEFEND YOURSELF.
AND YOU DO USE A FIREARM TO
DEFEND YOURSELF.
NO, WHY WOULDN'T YOU TRUST
330 MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OH
COUNTRY, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OM
COUNTRY, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OP
COUNTRY, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OS
COUNTRY, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OE
COUNTRY, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS ON
COUNTRY, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OO
CONCEIVABLE THREAT TO ANYBODY.
SO WHY CAN'T WE THINK OF A LAW
THAT SPARES THEM THESE
REGULATIONS.
IS ANYONE EVEN TRYING TO THINK
OF THAT?
>> OF COURSE THEY ARE.
>> Tucker: REALLY, WHO?
>> WE ARE TAKING IT STEP-BY-STE
STEP-BY-STEP.
ASK ANY SUBURBAN MOTHER, THAT IS
THE PROBLEM, POLITICALLY, THESE
PEOPLE THAT CARE -- THEY ARE
GOING TO BE LOST BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE --
>> Tucker: AT THE LEFT IS
MAKING THIS COUNTRY CHAOTIC AND
SCARY, AND SIMULTANEOUSLY TRYING
TO KEEP ME FROM DEFENDING
MYSELF.